republicans claim the administration is
sending mixed signals
on how it views those who seek asylum in
this country at the border versus those
who might be seeking asylum in this
country
from cuba and haiti dead set against
telling them
not in either country to try to come to
this country or
get into boats to come emigrate to the
united states
but very different policies at the
border that have senator steve daines
confuse the montana republican centers
it's on the finance committee energy
committee
kind enough to join us now senator um
it's a very good point
that we are potentially sending mixed
signals
um what do you think the white house
is saying here well
from what we're hearing from the
president uh it looks like president
biden wants
open border policies for everybody
except the cuban people
and perhaps that makes sense neil
because president biden
wouldn't want people to come into our
country who might give testimony
to the failures of socialism and
contradict
president biden's far-left agenda but
those images from the southern border
are just shocking it kneels just
yesterday i was in billings montana
having a briefing with our law
enforcement there uh chief of police
county sheriff what's not talked about
enough on the southern border
is the fact the illegal drugs were
coming across the heroin the fentanyl
the methamphetamines
we're going to see a record level
homicides in billings monsanto this year
we are in northern border states with a
southern border crisis
and is directly tied to mexican cartel
meth about 80 percent of our
felonies and violent crimes are tied to
drugs those drugs are coming in
from mexico so he is sending a
contradicting message the president
wide open border on the south he's
telling the cuban people
you're not allowed to come the united
states
you know um the argument was uh that he
was
looking at their safety as well as the
safety of american exiles
or cuban exiles in florida uh trying to
make the trip
south up to provide supplies food even a
means for
for cubans to come to the united states
that it's dangerous so
so don't do it but he did criticize
communism as a failed philosophy and and
and cuba has a failed state but you want
him to
act on that right what specifically
regarding cuba would you like to see him
do
well this notion the president saying
that the truck across the water
for cubans is dangerous and i i would
agree that is true
but the truck across the mexican desert
where these northern triangle refugees
are coming out of central america
it's equally dangerous especially the
high temperatures and as you know
neil right many of those folks are
families with small
children so that isn't a consistent
argument
there is a process to be followed for
seeking asylum and whether you are a
cuban or whether you are somebody from a
northern triangle country
follow the process the problem we have
in the southern border
is president biden has revoked the
policies that president trump put in
place
that said if you claim asylum you've got
to remain in mexico
until it's adjudicated that's common
sense and the contrast there is when
president biden
suspended president trump's policies
as a reporter earlier stated we're going
to see perhaps a
record level of illegal crossings in
this country
the month of june was the highest number
in 21 years
you know well i have you on on that
subject
senator the president has promised that
the justice department will appeal what
he calls a deeply disappointing ruling
by a federal judge in texas
on this program that protects uh certain
immigrants brought into the u.s uh and
and that
he'll he'll address what this judge
forgot
where are you on this and what does it
mean
to the children of illegals who grew up
in this country and now see it as their
country
yeah well there's a path forward here
neil with republicans and democrats
working together
to define a path to citizenship
that follows established paths and
processes that
many many americans now went through
that process
who once were not citizens and now our
citizens
but we are not going to go down a path
of granting amnesty there is
a path a process that millions have gone
through who are now american citizens we
should follow the same process uh that's
a solvable problem
uh and and i think we could find a
bipartisan solution hopefully
that would follow us through law and
established processes
senator well i have you uh obviously
chuck schumer
wants to begin at least debate voting on
this three and a half trillion dollar
so-called human infrastructure program
apart from that is the roughly one
trillion dollar real
infrastructure program infrastructure
only um
are you a yes vote on that on the
roughly one
trillion dollar plan that does seem to
have bipartisan support not necessarily
this three and a half trillion dollar
one that clearly does not
yeah well first of all we've got to see
the pay force you know how are you going
to pay for it we are 30 trillion dollars
in debt
so we're waiting to get clarity on what
the pay stores are
for the additional spending we'll also
uh
want to see what the what the cbo says
about it so that's going to come out
here soon
but i just have to make a comment on
that three and a half trillion dollar
social infrastructure package neil this
is massive
this would be the largest spending bill
passed over in a budget in the history
of our country this is a
massive spending bill it's a massive
tax increase it is a lurch to the left
like we've never seen before
neil it ought to be very concerning to
every american what's going on and by
the way it just takes
one democrat senator one because every
republican's gonna be opposed to it
we can get one democrat senator to
hopefully bring some common sense
and stop this uh that's that's what we
are hoping for but republicans are
completely left out
this negotiation on this three and a
half trillion dollar
massive democrat spending package
all right on the tax degrees what were
you referring to the fact he wants to
stick taxes on
the well to do are you talking about the
inflation that could
come as a result of it but that is a tax
on the nr
inflation is a tax increase for
everybody just it just starts to
uh starts to shrink the paycheck
but the tax credit i'm specifically
talking about here truly is
we're looking to raise capital gains
taxes you know o'neill to levels higher
than any oec
country in the in the world when you add
the state component that doubling
capital gains uh massive increase in the
death tax
as well as raising um taxes on
businesses the corporate tax rate which
again
if anybody's cheering right now neil
it's the chinese
if we want to continue to be competitive
to beat china we need to stick to
president trump's
and the republican tax package we passed
back in 2017.
that incentivizes growth and
incentivizes keeping jobs in america
all right the battle is on uh senator
danes thank you have a wonderful weekend
senator
uh steve daines of montana we'll be
following that back and forth on these
various spending packages